Q how do you feel like is like uh in
terms of just like filling in the space
that is missing there really wasn't
anything sort of that catered to to the
issues or
you know I think your guys's Mission
before and I I don't know why you know
obviously there's I'm sure in certain
markets there's like one-offs of people
who do like shows like this
aren't necessarily trying to take the
national approach to it so the
interesting thing Kev is that our
initial push wasn't for us to do a show
right so it's hard to tell the story and
leave that part out we didn't we wasn't
trying to jump you know in front of the
mic or in front of the camera grab just
make sure your mic's turned down a
little there you go to tell the story
yeah we just thought somebody should
right right when we first had that first
meeting with the PD it was like hey
you know we got some unrated space
overnight that's running uh are you
talking about at the beat
knrj in Arizona yes sir that's now the
bounce that's now the bounce that's
we're the reason they changed their name
because well they were crazy Ram just
also owns the beat trademark yeah so
there's that what yeah Ram just owns the
beat so they had to change the whole
situation but and we can talk about that
too but
we were in the streets Kevin you know
this more than more than a lot of people
when everything was happening in 2020 a
lot of people were outside with their
kids with their families like listen
there's some things that go that are
going on that have been going on for so
long and we just kind of collectively
all over it yeah for sure but the way
that it was covered on television even
on some broadcast media was just not
that you know call people rioters and
protesters I mean not protesters but
rioters and looters instead of
protesters so Rams is his idea was
listen
there's some people out there whose
voice only goes as far as a bullhorn
right it would be cool that we can just
have them come on the radio right and
have a place where they can say their
peace and tell their story right and we
got some unrated time overnight that's
running what don't drink and drive ads
or something right where we could you
know talk about that right and the
station was initially like yeah that'd
be a great idea yeah we should put
something together and then a month went
by and then a couple months went by and
then a few months went by and just in
the spirit I think in the spirit of
follow-up Ram just went and had a
meeting with you know I'll let you say
the gentleman's name RPD at the time
um
hey remember that thing we talked about
that everybody said would be a good idea
all right are we going to do that yeah
and there's so many things they could
have said back to us Kev that we would
have just had to take on the chin and
run with like hey you guys great idea
but we're going to want to do anything
divisive
hey guys wonderful concept you guys
talked about but we don't really do
political in this space have they said
something like that we thought it was BS
but if we could have took that on the
channel what they said or what he said
more specifically was we don't want to
do a black show
wow
and the reason why that part of the
story is important because Civic Cipher
now seems like hey those guys had a
great plan and they ran the play and it
worked that's not what happened right we
pitched an idea to the station they told
us initially okay and this is a at the
time
I mean still there's a hip-hop station
yes but it's a hip-hop station it's a
hip-hop station that plays nothing but
nothing but black music that was that
was my charge in Phoenix yes my charge
was that you know a station that plays
um 70 black artist and 100 black music
should also align itself be an ally to a
community in need where we're hurting
you know people are dying we're coming
together we're trying to change so that
we can create a better path forward for
our children right my father what's Fred
Rico doing now
so in real estate like every other bum
ass PD out there they can't get a job
hey man look I I haven't kept up I will
say this because it's important to say
it I talked to Fred
he wished me well on my journey and I
will leave it there but I don't know I
do want to say this too let me let me
say this because you know for folks that
aren't familiar with Civic Cipher
um you know was talking about you know
Kev listening to my CD books
um after Fred and I had our meeting I
don't think I don't even think you know
this
um you have to bear in mind I've been a
radio broadcaster my whole Adult Career
up to that point and when I decided to
resign after that meeting
um I had to come to terms with the fact
that I might never broadcast again and
that's a lot to come in terms with
because in Phoenix you know I was kind
of you know at that time especially so
for people who don't know you you
decided to resign after they said we're
not going to put the show on he said
Ramses I don't want to the way that they
said it I don't want to do a block it
had to do it the way they said it right
so I wrote my resignation letter but I
addressed it to the City of Phoenix
right
um because the Phoenix had given me my
ratings Phoenix had kept me on the air
across multiple stations and so forth
but I did make one phone call before I
posted that
I called you and you were in Mexico at
the time with your wife and I read that
I remember I was crying yeah I was into
because you imagine when I got to your
house you were still crying yeah the
emotion that goes into that and I didn't
know what was coming next but I read
that letter to you and you was like
there's dog there's no way you can write
that and not post it post it yeah posted
it and then got shared went viral
um the trades picked it up you know
everyone picked it up and then PD
started reaching out around the country
saying hey we'd like to carry that show
and then of course the podcast
partnership with I heart helped blow it
up even more and you know then the other
shows that I that I ended up doing it
just led to sort of The Snowball Effect
so we had to create that on the spot
when these people started reaching out
we had no name there was no show the
show didn't exist we just had an idea
but you know Rams is initial initially
resigned both of us from the beat like
okay we don't work here no more right
and then called me and told me and of
course right but just it was he was that
compelled he felt that strong in that
moment like imagine looking at for the
cameras imagine looking at him
we're not going to do a black show on
the hip-hop station like that's a crazy
it's a crazy thing to say out loud yeah
to me especially you know what I'm
saying so that decision kind of made
itself Kev and
then it was time to get to work yeah Q I
need you to commit to doing this with me
I don't know what it's going to become
because you know it's worked out now we
might top of the year we might be on
almost 70 stations yeah so it's worked
out now so it seemed like we had a plan
and we ran to play like nah it was just
the station made a decision for us we
don't want to do a black show made the
choice for us what happened after that
it just kind of came together so if you
believe in God or the universal you know
whatever your belief system is that's
kind of where those thanks go because we
had no idea and our minds were never
going to work in radio again because
ramses's letter burned the station down
he named names it was very it was very
very specific but had to be done in that
way yeah you know but but we figured
okay once this is published
I don't know how we're gonna do you know
as far as the career thing after this
yeah so once uh you you the letter goes
viral did they ever like uh they never
even replied to it or try to I had a
brief line of communication to uh the
general manager of the station because
you know we're at a point what's his
name again
um Paul Holton okay what's the other
guy's name that's always there the the
the other old dude that's been there
forever uh Michael Michael malice oh
yeah he was going by okay okay so
Michael wasn't involved but anyway uh
yeah I had a brief line of communication
because we're going back and forth in
the newspaper and then the trades you
know and they're saying it's this I'm
saying it's that you know what I mean
and of course they have to spend they
have a whole business to protect so they
don't mind reframing the conversation
The Narrative around they've been trying
to get somebody else to do the show yeah
yeah I think they hired Cedric ceballos
shout out to said that's my guy yeah but
they hired um him to do it and then I
think it was like Jackie Morales is
another name out in Arizona
um some folks to try to pick up the
slack because the community had since
charged that station with hey you should
be doing what this guy resigned about
you know what I mean so um you know
everybody ended up winning uh again I
kept a brief line of communication open
with Paul I still believe Paul to be you
know friendly with me but obviously
because of where he works in the
situation circumstance he probably can't
talk to me and I honestly I believe that
a lot of those people really had good
intentions it was just one person who
made the wrong decision at the wrong
time and said it the wrong way to the
wrong person because I've been I was the
president of the black student union in
college NAACP or BSU this isn't new to
me I've been on this this path for my
life trying to make sure everything is
fair and equal because you know we
reached me and you Kev we reach Heights
from playing with toys as a little kid
you know what I'm saying we reached High
School we'd have never thought
um and you know for me obviously it
comes with an additional charge for you
two you've been real real good about
that but it comes with a charge of okay
now we have to make sure that people
that don't make it to this height
um
we we're doing right by them we're
making the world a little bit better
place a little bit more accessible
um and you know helping change the
narrative so that you know we leave a
legacy that's not just we make some
bread